Wonderful. Thank you so
we got to the finally to the final
lecture of this course after um
several
several lectures. So I remind you that
that we've seen um well the foundations
of geometric deep learning uh
geometric priors and then different
domains whether it's graphs uh grids
and um
uh groups and manifolds um gauges and
then uh better actually didn't talk
about sequences and and time he talked
about um
about categories. So today I would like
to talk about some of the applications
particularly for graph neural networks
and then um maybe some directions that
that at least I personally believe to be
interesting and promising which are
maybe a little bit exotic but that might
be a way in which this domain can
evolve.
So I remind you that that we started
with this quote so I would like to close
with this quote about symmetry from from
Hermann Weyl that was really one big
idea that that you can trace back
to ancient times in in science uh in
mathematics in geometry in particular
and this is uh this is symmetry. And
we've seen that that we can apply this
principle on different types of objects
whether it's grids whether it's
homogeneous spaces graphs manifolds
meshes uh and probably even more general
and abstract structures to derive
learning architectures inductive biases
that that
uh serve the foundations to some of the
most recognized and widely used
architectures such as uh CNNs uh
deep sets transformers graph neural
networks uh different forms of intrinsic
and mesh CNNs and also well we didn't
talk about it but uh also for some
recurrent models such as LSTM
uh you can also derive them from
considerations of symmetry.
So the question is what's next? What uh
will be uh the next chapter in this uh
in this field?
And um
together with uh with uh my co-authors
we've been doing well already second
year in a row these kind of predictions
or summary
of uh
geometric and graph ML
in uh
what what has been exciting, what are
the promising directions by basically
interviewing some of the prominent
researchers in this field. So, we did it
last year, we did it this year as well.
And I would like to to
to to
refer to some quotes and then show how
they they might be manifesting
themselves. So, this is quote from Will
Hamilton. So, he's mainly known for the
the the graph stage framework and many
other um
uh papers uh on the topic.
And he was saying that that we've seen
mainly in 2020
uh uh the field come to terms with the
fundamental limitations of the message
passing paradigm.
So, uh the fact that for example message
passing is equivalent to the
Weisfeiler-Lehman graph isomorphism test
uh shows that certain structures cannot
be detected. And it requires uh methods
that that go beyond these limitations.
So, several ways we talked about some of
them. Um
I think Chris Bonner as well mentioned
some of them. So, uh one of such uh
ideas would be to go beyond
uh propagation of information between
nodes along the edges of the graph and
to use um
more exotic uh higher dimensional higher
order structures such as simplicial or
cellular complexes and define uh maybe
higher dimensional
uh analogies of the Weisfeiler-Lehman uh
color refinement schemes for these kind
of topological objects. And you can show
that these uh schemes are not only more
powerful theoretically, but also in some
applications they uh more naturally
model the structures that arise arise in
these architectures. And chemistry is
probably one example. So, it's
interesting that graph neural networks
as I've I've shown in the in the
introduction lecture uh
can be traced back to the to the
problems in chemoinformatics and even
the Weisfeiler-Lehman algorithm was
inspired by the work of of of Lederer,
who is was a chemist and was mainly
concerned with the problem of how to
organize and retrieve molecules
uh um using computational methods.
So, I'm personally surprised why a
chemist would think of a molecule as a
graph because chemists don't think of
molecules as collections of atom atoms
and
and and uh and chemical bonds, they
think of them as chemical structures or
maybe even reactions.
And therefore, graphs are not
necessarily the best way of representing
molecules. They indeed might contain all
the information there, but for example,
if you cannot with Weisfeiler-Lehman
test, you cannot detect even triangles,
let alone about cycles. And cycles
constitute an important structure in
organic molecules,
structures like aromatic rings are
extremely important. So, we want some
way of representing structures uh that
that capture this
prior knowledge or inductive biases in
chemistry. And cellular complexes appear
to be such structures.
So, another interesting direction is
explainable GNN. So, I think this is one
of the the common criticism for not only
for crafting all networks, but for deep
learning in general
is that they are not explainable. So,
there are several ways that this
explainability can be incorporated. So,
one of them is
modeling physical systems
is to try to to learn
message passing functions that are
physically
correct and interpretable. So, this is
a very nice paper by by Cranmer
from 2 years ago where they
learned on multi-particle system generic
message passing function and then they
regress symbolic equations that
essentially gives give you a closed-form
formula for how the the different
constituents of such a system interact
with each other.
Another topic is algorithmic reasoning.
I think that that was mentioned by Peter
where
it's an attempt to marry our algorithms
with neural networks to take advantages
of both worlds in terms of the
digitalization interpretability and
generalization across data and across
tasks.
And another interesting topic is causal
inference where we can try to build a
graph that that describes the causal
relations between different nodes. So
this is a very prominent and popular
topic nowadays in drug discovery where
you can now with modern technology you
can do high throughput
gene perturbations. So you can take a
cell and modify it and see how it reacts
for example to different drugs.
And from this you can try to build a
model of the disease and of the therapy
and understanding how different for
example
malignant cells
what what is the change in the
biochemistry would allow to to design
better better therapies for these
diseases.
And then of course there is a field of
knowledge graphs that I think has
historically stood a little bit apart
and many models that emerged in this
domain were to represent uh
the structure of knowledge graphs that
typically come in triplets where you
have two
objects and the relation between them.
So methods such as graph embeddings such
as trans E or trans R
were that we didn't discuss in this
course.
Were
emerged from this from this domain.
Now here is another quote. So this is
Thomas Kip that that you probably know
from the the GCN architecture
that that mentioned
this particular noteworthy trend in
graph ML is
the separation of computational and data
structures. So the graph in graph neural
networks at least traditionally
has been the same in input graph
used for the propagation of information.
And we've seen that in many cases this
is not necessarily friendly.
You can
get phenomena such as bottlenecks and
over squashing
when the graph itself
is not
appropriate for
for message passing. So, it might have
some bottlenecks that make this flow of
information complicated. So, there are
several works that try to
deal with it with graph rewiring. So,
the famous paper DGC
from the group of
Stefan Gumin in Munich. We also had a
paper at ICLR earlier this year that was
even awarded the the best paper
honorable mention where we showed that
Ricci curvature could be used to
understand these bottlenecks and
rewiring that that resembles a Ricci
flow a process from differential
geometry
could alleviate these bottlenecks and
make information flow
more efficient in graphs.
So, there is also interesting topic in
more traditional network science. So,
what is called network geometry trying
to think of graphs as discretizations of
continuous objects in particular of
hyperbolic spaces and then along these
lines
the
derivation of graph neural networks
as a discretization of physical process
described by differential equations. So,
Francesco Di Giovanni talked about it
and I will talk about it today as well.
So, he was talking about how to derive
the graph convolutional framework from
gradient flow of Dirichlet type energies
and then basically
um
giving back the credit to this
architecture that somehow the folklore
in the field
believes that that it's not powerful
enough.
Especially for dealing with heterophilic
graphs. So, what he showed is that this
is not true. So, you need to do channel
mixing appropriately in order to to to
make it
able to deal with
situations of heterophily.
Then interesting topic that in many
situations the graph is actually not a
static object. So, if you think of
social network or maybe different types
of biological graphs, they evolve over
time.
So, uh
dynamic graphs and neural networks to to
work on this kind of data are also a
new, relatively new and emerging field
of study.
And another topic is generative models.
So, generative models have been
uh
popularized probably with with
with guns, with adversarial neural
networks, and more recently with
diffusion models. So, now we have some
amazing
results such as DALL-E 2,
uh models that that can generate images
that look very realistic and can also
respond to to different
textual prompt.
So, something similar for graphs, in
particular in the domain of chemistry
for
synthesis of molecules,
is still uh to be done. So, it's an open
question. One of the difficulties there
are that that again the domain itself is
what you're what you're generating and
you don't have canonical ordering.
So, you need to to some probably
different procedures to do it.
So, in molecules, for example, one of
the the structures that that was done is
to to represent molecules as junction
trees and then have some kind of
vocabulary of these small structures.
Then, an interesting topic is
standardized evaluation. So, this was
this gave a big boost to to machine
learning and in particular in computer
vision with the ImageNet. So, this is
what
typically cited as the turning point for
the field in 2012 when convolutional
neural networks
smashed the the the ImageNet benchmark
by significant margin.
This is also what happened in the the
in protein folding
when AlphaFold was a newcomer that
outperformed other models that that were
based on probably decades of insights
and and intuition and know-how.
So, in graph neural networks now, there
is open graph benchmark that appeared
about 2 years ago and it's already a
standard evaluation tool that is used by
by researchers worldwide.
And then of course industrial
applications. So
graph neural networks are now broadly
used across the spectrum
in many different applications. So one
of them for example was to design new
chips. As you know it's
it's a combinatorial problem. Can be
formulated as reinforcement learning
with
with the help of graph neural networks.
And then another topic that I would
should say probably is overlooked in the
field is the compatibility
of algorithms with hardware.
So
when you implement a graph neural
network so it's very easy and maybe a
little bit laziness here to say that
let's throw it on a GPU and then well
GPU is powerful enough, right? It has
sufficient memory
to fit the graph and to to
basically we can we can work on it. The
problem of course is that
in applications where the graphs are
very large, you cannot do it anymore. So
you need to design algorithms that are
aware
of the hardware. And there are some
newcomers that compete with Nvidia such
as Graphcore
with their IPU architecture that that is
probably more suitable for certain types
of graph learning.
So it's an interesting interaction
between hardware
and and software.
And then of course applications ranging
anywhere from
from self-driving cars to to to protein
design to drug discovery to particle
physics.
So let me talk briefly about these. So I
will start maybe with social networks.
I work at Twitter
as my second job. So
in the social networks graph neural
networks have been used primarily for
recommender systems. So I think one of
the pioneers was
Pinterest with the PinSage. So that was
an architecture that productionized the
the Sage
type of
graph neural network architecture. Then
for example recent works from Uber
uh using uh graph neural networks for uh
uh for uh food recommendations.
And in recommender systems, typically,
what you try to do is to do edge
predictions. So, so we have nodes of the
graph, for example, bipartite graph that
can represent users and uh items that
they uh buy or they like. And based on
the edges that exist in this graph, you
can try to predict the probability of an
edge between
between a pair of such nodes.
And this is how most of these uh uh
these architectures work. So, this
figure is actually from paper on
AliGraph, which is a
a recommender system or a framework that
uh powers multiple recommender systems
in Alibaba.
So, I myself, with my students, we've
created a company that was acquired by
Twitter, and we're using graph neural
networks
to try to classify uh misinformation or
so-called fake news from the way that
they propagate on the social network,
and we are now part of Twitter, and we
work on uh different applications of
graph learning inside uh inside Twitter.
So, this this is
the team as it was acquired
uh 3 years ago.
Now, in 3D visions and uh vision and
graphics, so uh if you weigh uh if you
look at ways of representing
uh geometric data, so obviously, there
are multiple ways of uh thinking of uh
uh of three-dimensional objects. You can
think of them, for example, as volumes
and rasterize them using voxels, or you
can think of them as point clouds, or
you can think of them as discrete
manifolds,
or meshes.
So, this is, for example, typical input
signal from a lidar. So, it's a
uh specially structured point cloud.
This is what uh the the sensor
on a self-driving car sees, and you can
use uh this information, for example, to
predict
where the the the cars nearby will be
will be moving, right? So, some kind of
predictive capability that, for example,
will allow the self-driving car to try
to avoid uh uh accidents and and
situations that that might be dangerous
to the driver.
So, I I think I showed this a video as
well in my lecture about
manifold. So, this is example of motion
capture. So, they they here they face of
the actor is scanned in real time by 3D
sensor. This was actually a sensor that
that I've been developing at Intel.
That was another startup that we sold
10 years ago
that that became was
was was known as the RealSense
technology.
And here the problem is that they they
they motion of the input pose of the
actor's face is transferred is
synthesized in this Shrek-like looking
avatar. So, it's a problem of
correspondence and
and synthesis. So, you both find
correspondence between the noisy input
and the some canonical face
and then you
you deform it to repeat the input
structure.
We've been also working on
several applications where the input is
actually a two-dimensional image or a
video. So, the encoder is standard
convolutional neural network and and the
decoder is a mesh CNN and in particular
my student Dominik worked on hand pose
and shape reconstruction. This is
difficult problem because hand has a lot
of occlusions and and ambiguities.
And in collaboration with the British
startup I really I we showed this
application
at CPR 2 years ago
where we had real-time avatars running
on an iPhone
with detailed hands that were
reconstructed this way and I really was
acquired also almost 2 years ago by
Snap. So, now this is part of Snap
technology that that
that incorporates these methods.
Now, I mentioned applications in
physics.
So, this is quote from Kyle Cranmer. So,
he's a professor at NYU.
I think actually he recently moved from
NYU. And he was one of the discoverers
of the Higgs boson at LHC.
And he was very keen on using graph
neural networks for different
applications in particle physics. And
this is LHC, so this is actually one of
the detectors
in the ATLAS experiment that that was
used to detect the Higgs boson. And the
the way that that graph neural networks
are used there is that you can
describe interactions of different
particles as this kind of particle jet.
So, particles are created and disappear
and
produce new particles when they
interact. So, this can be described as a
graph, and then you can use graph neural
networks for example both to reconstruct
these these jets from the the
observations in the detector as well as
classify some events. So, I myself with
Joan, we had a collaboration with the
team of
uh IceCube, which is a neutrino
observatory
in the South Pole. It's a cubic
kilometer of detectors. And why you need
such a big detector? Because neutrinos,
as you probably know from courses in
physics, they don't interact with
matter, so they very rarely interact
with matter. And you you know, to pick
up these interactions, you need a very
large detector. So, this detector is
actually a very large array of
photomultipliers that see light uh what
is called Cherenkov radiation when
neutrinos interact with the the
matter
in this in this ice. And because ice is
transparent, they can see this glow as
it's picked up by the the by the
uh photodetectors, and this is an
example of a signal that that
the different energy and different time
that is deposited on the detectors. And
looking at the signal, you can try to
classify whether this neutrino comes
from an astrophysical source somewhere
deep and far in the universe, or is it
some background for example
coming from our nearby sun.
So, um
this actually has been used the neutrino
observatory was used for first
multi-messenger astronomy, what is
called. So, you can detect a source of
neutrino and then point a standard
telescope and see actually where it
comes from from the bottom supernova
explosion.
Then other interesting applications, so
I think this was from DeepMind fluid
simulation
where different multi-particle systems
were modeled as graph neural networks
where the edges represent different
types of interactions and instead of
solving
a complicated differential equation that
governs this this flow
of of fluids or or
that is notoriously complicated
equations such as Navier-Stokes
uh
this can be
compressed in a sense by by graph neural
networks.
So
in biology and in drug discovery
graph neural networks right and more
generally geometric deep learning
techniques have been used also quite
extensively. So many of the problems
again as I mentioned come from chemistry
and here we're in particular we're
talking about biochemistry
and in particular we're talking about
proteins. So as you probably know
proteins are uh
chemical molecules that are encoded in
our DNA. So our life as we know on Earth
we don't know any other life forms that
is not based on proteins.
So proteins are encoded in
our DNA. So proteins are composed of
different amino acids. So there are 20
what is called proteinogenic amino
acids. Each triplet of nucleotides in
our DNA encodes one amino acid that is
then inside the cell using special
chemical machinery is becomes a protein.
So cells essentially are built to
produce proteins that that
make them work.
And basically it's a very long chain of
these of these simple building blocks
amino acids that under the influence of
electrostatic forces folds into
complicated structures such as sheets or
helices
and
you can think of this
analogy the snake toy that that is
one-dimensional structure, but you can
fold this into many different uh many
different shapes.
And the problem of protein folding,
basically predicting how the structure
will look like given a sequence, has
been a classical problem in structural
biology already from the '70s. So,
Christian Anfinsen in the '70s
conjectured that
the folding structure of the protein can
be fully determined by the amino acid
sequence.
And there was a kind of image that that
was called CASP
in structural biology domain that that
people tried to to were competing trying
to predict the structure from sequence.
And in 2018, AlphaFold from DeepMind
significantly outperformed
the
the the competing approaches. So, that
was a kind of image at the moment in
structural biology. And then
2 years ago, AlphaFold 2
performed even better. And AlphaFold 2,
as we'll hear in the last lecture
by one of the authors,
is actually a geometric architecture,
and it uses a component that is called
in Brian point attention,
which is what we called
equivariant
graph neural network, or equivariant
message passing.
And proteins are really ubiquitous. So,
any more or less any biological system
you pick up, whether it's transferring
oxygen to our cells, or defense against
pathogens, all right, antibodies are
proteins. So, a lot of these
a lot of these mechanisms are powered by
proteins. So, any chemical reaction that
happens in the body is catalyzed by
enzymes, which are proteins. Even the
our skin has its
elastic structure thanks to a special
protein that is called collagen. When we
get older, we lose it, so that's why we
have wrinkles on our face.
And
proteins, because they are so ubiquitous
and they appear more or less in every
biochemical system, they are standard
targets for
for drugs.
So, typically the way that it looks, you
have a protein that that
is responsible for something,
and it has these kind of pocket-like
structures. And uh the the development
of drugs tries to find
uh a small molecule that will fit into
this
uh into this pocket
and will inhibit the interaction of the
protein. So, it will block the protein
from interacting with some other
proteins and as result certain system
will be activated or disrupted. So, uh
most of the drugs are actually
inhibitors of protein receptors.
And what is shown here is uh actually
it's not a drug. Well, it's a drug-like
substance. It's caffeine or more
correctly one of the
uh substances from the same class that
is called xanthines. And this is what
happens when you drink uh your coffee in
the morning. So, this molecule uh gets
into your bloodstream, crosses the the
blood-brain barrier, and binds to
adenosine receptor in the brain.
And this is what makes you awake and
happy and so on.
But many um
targets are actually that they are now
interesting for for the
biopharmaceutical industry,
they don't have this kind of pocket-like
structure. Probably one good example is
uh what is called the program uh program
death uh complex. So, these are two
proteins that interact with each other
and their interface is flat. So, they
don't have any pockets. And these uh
kind of targets are considered uh hard
to drug or even undruggable by
traditional small molecules because
there is nowhere to fit
these uh these small molecule there. And
um the the analogy here that that you
want to think of is a kind of a lock and
the key metaphor. So, we have
complementary geometric structures. So,
not only geometric, they're also charged
surfaces.
And uh in this particular example of
PD-1 and PD-L1,
uh the program death complex, uh it
appeared to have uh extremely important
role in um cancer therapy because
uh basically what it's responsible for
is to disabling the immune system from
killing uh our own healthy tissue.
And uh uh this is what some types of
cancer uh produce and this protein
prevents the the malignant cells to be
destroyed by the normal action of T
cells in the immune system.
So, the idea of immunotherapy or better
called checkpoint immunotherapy is to
block one of these proteins, PD-1,
PD-L1, and it then allows the the immune
system to take control back.
And destroy the the tumor. So, this was
a very important discovery that was
awarded the Nobel Prize in Medicine
in 2018.
Now, in order to design this kind of uh
these drugs, right? So, this is a drug
of a new type that is called biological
drug or biologic,
you need to solve in a sense an inverse
folding problem. So, instead of going
from amino acid sequence to structure,
you want to
to to find out what is the the amino
acid sequence, right? What is the
protein that will fold in a certain way,
that will have certain geometric
structure that will give it certain uh
functional properties. So, you probably
at a conceptual level you can say that
we go from sequence to structure to
function.
And uh unfortunately, this is not a
straight forward sequences are obviously
very easy to analyze in some early works
in bioinformatics tried to to look at
sequences and compare them as
essentially strings or substrings.
Now, you can find proteins that have uh
very similar sequences and different
structures. So, it might be some unhappy
mutation and just in one amino acid that
that results in completely different
folding or vice versa. You can find
similar structures
that that uh come from different
sequences. So, different sequences will
fold in the same way. And then you can
also find proteins with very different
structures that for example bind some
molecules or they have the same
function,
but they come from very different
structures and this is also happening
what is called convergent evolution. So,
when different organisms evolve
separately, but you need a protein that
that fulfills the same function. So, you
get to it from so to say different
directions evolutionarily.
So, what I did with my collaborators in
in Switzerland, so we designed
uh uh geometric architectures so that
well in this case we represent the
proteins as surfaces and we try to
predict where and how they will be
binding. And this was an important step
in designing new proteins, what is
called de novo or from scratch design,
where the protein, uh,
with desired properties, for example,
binding to the oncological PD-1
target, uh,
uh, is built in this way.
And, uh, that was, uh,
uh,
an architecture that we called Massive.
We had also several follow-up works,
including some new designed, uh, binders
for both oncological
oncological targets as well as for the,
for example, coronavirus
spike protein. So, it's data-driven
architecture that that significantly
accelerates and make makes, uh,
principled rational design of proteins,
uh,
significantly
easier task. So, hopefully at some point
it will be used in the development of
new of new therapeutic, uh,
compounds.
So, I mentioned, well, obviously drug
design. So, in general, the problem of
drug design is that it takes quite some
time
to to deliver, uh, a drug to the market.
So, typically 10 years, about $2 billion
investment. And the reason is that, uh,
drugs,
uh,
are discarded at different stages of
testing. So, they are subjected to very
rigorous, uh, testing process, clinical
trials. And one of the the issues is
that the space of search for different
molecules that could be used as
potential drug is extremely large, so
something like 10 to the power of 60.
So, it's combinatorial complexity.
Whereas something that you can test in
the lab, well, maybe now with
high-throughput chemistry you can test
tens if not hundreds of thousands of
molecules, but still the gap is huge.
So, this gap is typically breached
computationally, and that's why you can
use, uh, different models such as, for
example, molecular dynamics. So, you can
try to solve quantum mechanical systems
to understand, for example, how proteins
fold and how they interact with other
proteins or with small molecules. You
can use maybe some approximations such
as density functional theory. So, graph
neural networks have actually been
reintroduced to chemistry from from
where they originated, in particular the
work of Justin Gilmer from 2017, exactly
as a way of
make more efficient these kind of
predictions, or predicting
chemical properties of molecules such as
solubility, toxicity, and so on. So, all
the different properties that that you
need to know in order to to choose your
suitable candidates for for a drug.
And graph neural networks have made some
splash
not only in the the in the machine
learning community, but also outside of
it, even in the popular press,
with this publication of a paper in
Cell, which is one of the the major
journals in in in biology,
where the group at MIT used graph neural
networks as part of a pipeline to
discover new antibiotic compounds. In
particular, they showed that the drug
was that was tested for
against diabetes
had very powerful antibiotic properties
and could be applied also to antibiotic
resistant organisms. So, as you probably
know, we already have a lot of
bacteria that are resistant to to
antibiotics that
are now available, and I think the
estimate is that more than a million
people each year die from these
diseases. So, it's just a matter of time
when we have a pandemic
on the global scale that will be caused
by these
antibiotic resistant pathogens. So, we
need very urgently new class of
antibiotics.
And this is probably one way of
discovering them.
Then another way of
using new drugs, so instead of
developing a new molecule that takes a
lot of time and a lot of money to
develop, you can actually take approved
molecules that are known to be safe and
use them in combination, and some
combinations actually have a non-linear
synergistic effect. Some others have
antagonistic or maybe a side effects and
this was one of the first uses of graph
neural networks by Marinka Zitnik, who
is now
a professor at Harvard Medical School.
So, she used graph neural networks to
predict
uh interactions
of uh combinations of drugs. So, this is
also standard way of uh administrating
treatments,
uh what is called polypharmacy, when or
combination drug therapy where we use
multiple drugs at the same time.
And uh the way that that uh she
considered it is by looking at protein
to protein interaction network. So,
that's a graph that represents
graphically how the biology of the body
works. So, the proteins they are
represent uh drug targets. So, this is
modeled by drug to protein interaction
graph. And then she tried to predict
edges in the drug to drug interaction
uh graph uh graph where you knew the
nodes but not the edges. So, um
the the system was called Decagon and
it has been one of as I said, one of the
early successes of these uh kind of
techniques. With my collaborators at
Imperial College, we tried to take these
ideas to the domain of food and you
probably know that
food is uh
full with compounds that belong to the
same chemical classes as some
therapeutic drugs.
And it's not surprising. So, many drugs
that actually exist uh
nowadays, especially drugs against
cancer,
they are have natural uh analogs
in the plant kingdom. So, if you take
for example, a drug like uh
camptothecin, so it's a compound that is
found in the bark of a tree that grows
in China and four of its synthetic
analogs are used uh against cancer as
chemotherapeutic agents. And there are
many other examples. So, probably if you
take even a very uh
common drug like aspirin, so aspirin the
chemical name is acetylsalicylic acid
and uh salicyl comes from the the name
of the willow tree in Latin, salix. So,
it has been known from antiquity for its
analgesic properties.
So, bottom line, we have a lot of stuff
that that comes with our food that we
have no clue what it does. So, it's kind
of dark matter of nutrition. So, uh you
it's not tracked by regulators, right?
So, if you buy packaged food, you will
see probably content of
of proteins and fats and carbohydrates
and vitamins and minerals, but not
something like flavonoids or indoles.
Uh and so on and so on. We wanted to
understand
uh basically how these things work.
And uh to do this, we tried to uh
to to look at the way that that
compounds interact with protein targets.
And if we have some uh
uh examples of drugs, for example, that
that work against cancer, so we can take
FDA-approved anti-cancer drugs, and we
can train a classifier that predicts
anti-cancer drug likeness from the way
that the compound interacts with with
target proteins. And then we can apply
to compounds that are found in food. And
uh doing this, we can construct a map of
different foods and the way that that
the kind of compounds that they contain
and share.
And uh well, obviously, it is slightly
more complicated than I'm describing, so
we also had sort of to look at different
mechanisms that that would be convincing
to to to to uh
to biologists and and medics
that that it really does what what is
expected. So, this way we we had to mine
automatically uh medical literature in
the cancer
community. So, for example, looking for
uh effects such as anti-proliferation or
anti-angiogenesis uh anti-angiogenesis,
so the the the the growth of blood
vessels that is typically associated
with cancer. And using this, we were
able to to detect these compounds in
food
uh that that have potentially
anti-cancer drug-like properties. So,
what was cool in this project was
collaboration with chef Bruno Barbieri.
So, he's very famous Italian chef and
the judge of MasterChef Italy,
a TV show. And he used the compounds
that we identified to to present recipes
that in this case contained
compounds that that have potential
antiviral
properties.
So, in the remaining time, let me say a
few words about some future directions.
So, this was actually be will be
more or less the same talk that I gave
here in Padua in WCCI
conference on computational
intelligence.
And
if we look if we take a step back and
look at graph neural networks, right, as
we discussed them. So, there is a little
bit of kind of asymmetry or injustice in
the sense that we typically assume that
the data is contained in the nodes, and
then the edges of the graph are used to
propagate this information, right, in in
the form of message passing.
And basically, the structure of the
graph is somehow captured by the way
that we send information in it. So, as
we know from the Weisfeiler-Lehman test,
right, that is equivalent to message
passing,
that we can discover certain graph
structures
by basically by sending information to
to our neighbors.
So, I think it's maybe slightly
exaggerating, we can say that the nodes
are data and the edges are computation.
And
we see two problems in this, right? So,
the problem that we use the same graph
as a data and the computational object.
One of them is that some structures
cannot be detected by message passing,
right? So, here you can see an example
that would be deemed equivalent by the
Weisfeiler-Lehman algorithm. So, in this
case, we can
attach some additional information to
the nodes and the edges, for example, by
looking at
some substructures,
like counting, for example, the number
of triangles or cycles in the graph. And
this is what is typically known as
positional structural encoding.
Another problem is that some graphs
might be very unfriendly for passing
information. So,
think of this graph where you have a
bottleneck, and you need to squeeze all
the information into these pair of nodes
that that these two communities.
So, the standard remedy in the
literature is graph rewiring, where
you're allowed to change the graph
in a way that that will make facilitate
the propagation of information.
Now, another thing is that if you look
at the broader perspective of geometric
deep learning,
then we have different structures such
as grids or meshes and then graphs, and
graphs really stand apart in the
following sense that you can think of a
grid as a discretization of the plane,
for example. You can think of a mesh as
a discretization of a manifold. So, they
all have some kind of underlying
continuous objects. But, what is the
continuous analogy of graph?
So, this is something that is not very
clear. And if we compare the the kind of
structures, right, in these objects and
the the amount of ambiguity, so grids
are probably the most structured
objects. We don't have any ambiguity. If
I look at the neighbors of a node in a
grid, then we have
very well prescribed canonical ordering.
So, I can say that I have a neighbor at
the top, a neighbor at the bottom, and
the right, and the left.
So, there is no ambiguity whatsoever. In
a mesh, we have slightly
more ambiguity.
And the ambiguity here is that I cannot
I I can still choose arbitrarily
the first node, right? But, once
I choose it, then I can order all the
rest of the nodes, for example, in
clockwise orientation. So, remember that
we talked about gauge
gauge ambiguity, so the choice of the
local system of coordinates. So, exactly
here we have this rotation or cyclic
shift ambiguity when we talk about
meshes. In graphs, on the other hand, we
have very general permutation. So,
graphs, out of these structures, they
have the least structure, right? So,
they have the most ambiguity.
And um
what we are trying to say is that
we can take inspiration for designing
graph neural networks
from physical systems. So, we can use a
physical system as a metaphor for
learning. And this is a from a cool
paper that appeared in nature earlier
this year where they incorporated
uh
um
real-life physical systems uh such as
electronic circuit or an optical
uh setup into deep learning pipelines.
You can back propagate through this
system. So, this is not what we are
trying to say. So, we want to use a
metaphorically a physical system as a
model for learning. And again, this is
probably not a very new idea. So, uh you
can think of a system that is
parameterized by maybe by a small number
of parameters, and then you try to reach
a certain state by uh some trajectory in
this control in the in this parameter
space.
And uh this is what we
Yeah.
Question? Yeah, there's a question.
Yes. So, what makes graph unsuitable for
message passing?
So, what makes graphs unsuitable for
message passing? So, uh some graphs are
not I wouldn't say unsuitable. They are
not very friendly.
So, um
well, I I I have a slide about it, but
let me anticipate. So, what happens is
the following situation then.
When you have uh
the structure of the graph is such that
it has many neighbors, right? So,
technically speaking, this is what we
call volume growth. So, when uh the
volume growth is exponential, this
happens for example in social networks,
in small world graphs, where if you look
at the neighbors of the neighbors of the
neighbors, then the number explodes
exponentially.
So, we have a too many neighbors with
their features.
And uh if my problem depends on uh
uh
on information from nodes that are
several hops away,
I get into a situation when I need to
squeeze a lot of information into a
single feature vector. And this is
called over squashing.
So, uh in this case, the graph is uh not
friendly for message passing. So, it's
difficult to propagate information on
such a graph.
Uh well, I will get uh to to a for more
formal uh description of this uh of this
situation. So, so bear with me for for a
few minutes.
Okay?
Any questions? Yeah, there is another
question. Yes. There's another question.
Yeah.
Applying
learning to the recommendation system,
is it possible to make a recommendation
system based on the similarity of
content and users at the same time?
Well, so this is more or less what you
try, right? So, this will probably be
described by some features that you have
associated with users and with
and with the with content. So, one of
the issues with using graph neural
networks for
recommender systems is that um
is is structural ambiguity. So, what I
mean by this is the following. So, if
you have uh
uh nodes in a graph, right? So, if I
have uh a pair of nodes
and some structure around it, and I'm I
have an edge, and I'm trying to predict
whether this edge should be here or not.
If I have another part of the graph
which structurally looks the same, then
when I'm using a graph neural network to
embed the nodes, so usually this kind of
recommender systems, they
they represent the graph in some vector
space. So, every node corresponds to a
vector.
And then these different structures,
even though they're completely unrelated
and they're located in different parts
of the graph, will be indistinguishable.
So, they have the same vector
representation. And as a result, I will
be
predicting edges where they shouldn't be
edges.
So, that's why
the the the way that that graph neural
networks are used to to predict to
predict edges in graphs is actually as a
an edge classification problem. So, or
subgraph classification. So, you look at
the graph that surrounds an edge, and
you try to classify it, right? So, you
say if it's if it's one, then there is
an edge between the two nodes in this
graph. And if it's zero, then there is
no edge. This ambiguity actually makes
graph neural networks uh
work problematically for for each
connection.
Okay?
So, let's continue. So,
basically we are looking for physical
metaphors for physical systems that when
discretized will give rise to graph
neural networks. And probably the most
obvious thing that can come to your mind
when you deal with propagation of
information, this is diffusion
equations, right? So, I I
hope that that you've seen diffusion
equations in this or another form in
some basic
calculus or differential
courses. So,
what is a diffusion equation?
Essentially, you have some quantity,
let's say temperature on some domain,
right? On some
some
medium.
So, let's say in the plane, the the
different colors represent different
values of temperature. Now, the
difference or the gradient in the
temperature at different points create
what is called the heat flux. So, there
is a flow of temperature from hot to
cold,
right? And also temperature, unless you
have sources of heat, is not created out
of nowhere and doesn't disappear
anywhere. So, there is some conservation
condition. And this conservation
condition tells you that
the only reason why temperature changes
in time infinitesimally
is because there is this heat flux.
Okay? So, put together, this gives you
a diffusion equation. So, the left-hand
side tells you that the the
instantaneous change in the temperature,
X here denotes temperature at point U
and at time T,
and the right-hand side is roughly tells
you how much heat flux goes
through a point, and it's also scaled by
what's called a diffusivity constant.
So, the diffusivity constant can be a
function in general, can depend on
position and orientation. In the
simplest case, it's constant everywhere,
so then you can take it out of the
divergence. And as you know, divergence
of the gradient is the Laplacian
operator. So, we call these kind of
diffusion equations homogeneous and
isotropic.
And you can interpret it as a gradient
flow of Dirichlet energy. So, if you
remember Francesco's lecture, so that's
exactly what it is.
So, the diffusion energy measures how
smooth your signal is.
And
basically, the the diffusion equation
produces
a gradient flow that that tries to
reduce this energy to zero.
And in the Euclidean case, you can also
write it as in closed form as
convolution with a Gaussian filter. So,
essentially, it's a low-pass filtering
process.
And there are obviously more interesting
versions of the diffusion equation. So,
you can make the diffusivity position
dependent. So, in this case, we call the
diffusion non-homogeneous. Or you can
also make it not only position, but also
direction dependent. And in this case,
it's called anisotropic.
So, isotropic means
same in every direction.
Um and these kind of equations attracted
a lot of attention about 30 years ago,
starting from the seminal work of Pietro
Perona and Jitendra Malik.
Uh and what they said is the following
thing. So,
you there is this one-to-one
correspondence between
low-pass filtering
and diffusion equation. So, if you take
an image,
Isaac Newton in this case, and you apply
to it a diffusion equation, you get
low-pass filter, right? So, an image in
the middle.
And this way, you can remove noise from
the image, right? You will average it
out. But of course, this is not an image
that you want to see because by doing
this kind of diffusion, you also
destroyed sharp discontinuities that are
very important for visual perception.
So, the the the discontinuities what is
called edges in the image.
So, what they propose is to say, let's
make a diffusion adaptive. So, the
diffusion will be controlled by some
function that is inversely proportional
to the norm of the gradient. So, it's an
edge indicator. In other words, when the
diffusion sees that the pixels
are different from the the pixel at
which I the diffusion kernel is
positioned, then we'll slow down or stop
the diffusion. So, the diffusion, in
other words, will not be mixing pixels
of different color.
And this is what happens when you do
this process, so this non-linear
diffusion on the right, you see that it
removes noise from continuous regions,
but it preserves the important
discontinuities.
And this is really opened an entire
field of variational and PDE-based image
processing, and it was mathematically
admittedly very aesthetic and very
pleasant concept. So, you start with a
functional
that tells you uh
basically how your image should look
like, right? So, functional is a kind of
functional functions, right? That gives
a number assigns a number to a function.
Images in this case are measured are
modeled as as functions.
And then you can derive optimality
conditions, so these are called
Euler-Lagrange equations. So, it's a
partial differential equation that
uh gives you a gradient flow, so a kind
of minimization process for this
functional. So, you start with an image,
you evolve it with PDE, and then it
flows to the minimum of this functional,
like the Dirichlet energy and the the
diffusion
the the the diffusion equation.
Now, why I think it would be fair to say
why these methods have almost
disappeared
in the past years after the emergence of
deep learning exactly for the same
reason why
all the handcrafted descriptors in
computer vision have disappeared, and
this is because it's very difficult to
design something a priori that will work
for any kind of data and for any kind of
task. And that's where deep learning
actually was the the monumental
difference.
And what we are trying to do in our work
is to to uh to reinterpret these
methods, adapt them to to to the deep
learning context, and apply them to
graphs.
So, what's the difference between
closed-form solution of the heat
diffusion and random walks? Well, random
walks you can interpret them as some
form of diffusion.
So, there there are some nuances, so
usually these are not symmetric, but
otherwise, yeah, you can think of random
walks as a kind of discrete diffusion
process. Yeah. So, that that's a very
good question.
Um and then uh basically we can
formulate a a diffusion equation on the
graph. So, in this case, remember that
we have basically these three
ingredients. So, we have the gradient.
So, the gradient in this case will be
just the difference between the features
at end points of an edge.
Then we have the diffusivity function.
So, it's some non-linear function that
depends on the
that that weights every edge
uh by something some scalar number that
that that depends on the features at the
two end points. And then we have the
divergence that essentially sums all the
edges that that emanate from a node.
Now, pay attention that the time here is
continuous. So, we have a
differential equation
that is non-linear and needs to be
solved numerically.
So, now I should say that the the
difference in terminology between PDEs
and ODEs, so this is actually
technically speaking a system of coupled
ordinary differential equation for each
node. So,
ODE or PDE,
the only difference is that in PDEs you
have
also discretization of the spatial
domain, not only the time.
And well, we'll get to it in a second.
So, graph is
inherently discrete object. So, so
we want also to discretize the graph.
So, think of it as discretization of
a continuous object. Okay? But here we
already get the space discretized. We
need to discretize time.
And the simplest way is just to take
fixed
steps of fixed size.
And this is what is called explicit or
forward Euler scheme.
Where you take just forward differences
in time and this is what you get.
So, you get uh
uh evolution equation of this form. So,
if I rearrange the terms a little bit,
what surprisingly find that you can
interpret uh graph attention networks
that you've seen with better as a
particular discretization of this graph
diffusion equation. So, what we call
attention is actually diffusivity
function that is normalized in a special
way.
Okay, and no nonlinearity in this case
and a unit step size.
And but of course we don't need to to
use only an explicit scheme. So there is
a zillion of different numerical schemes
to discretize discretize differential
equations. So we can use implicit
schemes, we can use semi-implicit
multi-step schemes such as Runge-Kutta.
So
numerical analysis has probably more
than 150 years of experience on these
different different discretizations. And
the way that it works, let's say that
you're you're trying to solve a node
classification problem. So you will
start with some initial features, maybe
after some encoding.
Then you will diffuse them by parametric
diffusion equation where the the the
diffusivity function is parameterized.
And then you will read out the the the
resulting node features, maybe with some
decoder that is denoted here by psi.
And basically
in this case A, the diffusivity function
is learnable.
If we make it independent of time, it
means that
I will have shared weights across
layers. So now the analogy of layers
will be
the steps of the iterative solver.
And we don't have
traditional notion of depth.
We have now the diffusion time. And I
can discretize it differently. I can use
for example adaptive steps. So I can
have bigger steps where necessary and
smaller steps where it's required.
And one of the the reasons why you can
why why you should be doing it is for
example
in traditional graph neural networks
it's difficult to make them deep.
One of the the reasons is that that you
get
phenomena such as over-smoothing.
So with in this way you can you can
overcome this this phenomenon.
So
the question is what is X refers to
edges and what is K and R?
So in this case K is the number of
layers.
T capital is the diffusion time. Tau is
the step size.
I didn't see the R.
This is probably what you meant by tau,
right?
Yeah, tau is the step size.
So, if you make uh constant uh steps in
time.
Now, you can think of it maybe you can
say ask, "Okay, why are we doing it?"
So, this is just looks like a a formal
exercise and basically you get the same
stuff but just from different
considerations, I think.
It gives a new perspective on uh well,
on classical or well-known problems in
graph neural networks such as over
smoothing and bottlenecks, but also not
only that you can interpret existing
architectures such as GAT as
discretization of uh diffusion equation,
which is of course nice, but also some
solvers such as multigrid solvers or
multistep solvers, they don't have
immediate uh analogies or uh
uh immediate instances
in the graph learning uh literature.
And it means that maybe there will be
future architectures that will be
exploiting these kind of solvers.
And then of course uh
by by basically by interpreting graph
neural networks as discretized
differential equations, we can also
leverage huge literature from these
domains such as uh stability and
convergence guarantees that are very
important to total understanding and
analyzing the the properties of of graph
neural networks. And furthermore, well,
I I will show
in later in the last slides
uh it also offers
links to other maybe more exotic fields
such as differential geometry and
algebraic topology that is far less
known
in the GNN literature and in I would say
in machine learning in general.
So, let me take you back again to where
we started, right? So, we started with
diffusion and the analogy was diffusion
on images, right? Or on grids.
So, on grids when you discretize your
diffusion equation, you have
many ways of doing it. So, in
particular, let's say that you take
isotropic homogeneous diffusion that
that involves the Laplacian operator.
These are three different ways I can
discretize the Laplacian, right? So, I
can take for example the typically four
neighbors uh or I can rotate everything
by 45 degrees and take other four
neighbors or I can take more distant
neighbors. Or because the operators are
linear, any convex combination of these
discretizations is also a valid
discretization of the Laplacian. So you
see that on a grid
basically the
the way that the graph that you build to
discretize your operators is completely
arbitrary.
Right, so it's mainly determined by
numerical convenience. So I can change
it the way I want. I can even discretize
uh uh my domain differently at every
point.
So
what I'm trying to say is that we want
to to think of our graphs in graph
neural networks in a similar way. So we
want to say that that I'm allowed to
change the graph.
And the graph will be changed based on
uh
whatever is more convenient for the
problem I'm trying to solve.
And here again I will appeal to to
previous works that have been done in
the
computer vision and image processing
community and we've seen this nonlinear
of Perona-Malik.
Uh another model that that was developed
also in the '90s actually by my PhD
advisor Ron Kimmel
was non-Euclidean diffusion. So in this
case we consider the image as a manifold
that is embedded in a joint space that
contains positional coordinates and
feature coordinates. So in case of an
image the positional coordinates will be
just the XY coordinates of the pixel and
the feature coordinates will be for
example the colors, RGB colors. So with
this model the image is considered as a
two-dimensional manifold or a surface in
R5, right? So we have the XY and then
RGB. And it's
a manifold that is embedded or
geometrically realized in this
high-dimensional space. So
basically we are talking about
Riemannian manifolds so there is a
canonical way
that we can define a Riemannian metric
on this manifold by the pullback
mechanism. Remember we talked about it
when we discussed manifolds. So I have a
particular Riemannian metric with
respect to which I can write derivatives
such as the Laplacian. This is called
the Laplace-Beltrami operator, and the
diffusion equation
on this manifold
is actually a gradient flow of a
generalization of the Dirichlet energy
that is called the Polyakov functional.
So, it's an energy that is used in
high-energy
physics in string theory.
So, uh
basically, how does it apply to graphs?
So, on a graph, we can say that uh now
every node comes with two types of
coordinates. I have the the the standard
feature coordinates that I denote by X,
but I also have positional coordinates
that I denote by U. So, we embed the
graph in some space. It doesn't need to
be an exact
representation from which I can
reproduce the graph. What I'm using it
for is to
uh make some kind of
continuous graph evolving. And what I
mean by this is that I'm evolving by my
diffusion equation both coordinates, U
and V, right? As written here.
So, the the diffusion equation with
learnable diffusivity operates on the
joint coordinates, Z and Z, right? U and
X.
Then, the evolution of the X component,
the feature component, is the standard
feature diffusion, but the evolution of
U, the positional component, it can
bring some nodes closer or further away
from each other. And if I see that two
nodes come close together, then I can
say, "Okay, I will create an edge here."
Right? Or if they drift apart, I can
say, "I can cut this edge because these
nodes should not interact anymore." So,
this is a kind of graph evolving that is
done continuously on the fly.
And probably the best way to visualize
it with this animation. So, this is the
Cora graph,
which is a small citation network. So,
the colors here represent
uh different features, a low-dimensional
projection. The positions of the circles
represent
a two-dimensional positional encoding.
And the task here is node
classification. So, we want to obtain
clear classes, and you see that the
classes are obtained both in the
features and in the positions of the
nodes. And you see it also that the
graph changes as the evolution happens.
So, some of the edges when the nodes
become far away are cut.
Okay, so that's how this graph filter by
flow works.
Now, uh you may find it a little bit um
disturbing or maybe even even bizarre to
see uh
at least for for traditional image
processing. So, you do a filtering or
some some some process on uh a domain
that is changing under your feet, right?
So, the domain is evolving together with
the data on the domain.
But, this is actually a very common
viewpoint in differential geometry and
it's very common in differential
geometry to take a manifold and evolve
it by some differential equation and in
particular you evolve uh the metric of
the manifold or Riemannian manifold. And
the most famous way of doing it with
such evolution equation is called the
Ricci flow where you uh evolve the the
Riemannian metric according to the Ricci
curvature tensor.
So, this is an equation that is shown
here. G is the if you remember from the
lecture of manifolds is the the
Riemannian metric tensor. On the right
hand side I have curvature tensor. So,
structure it looks very much like the
diffusion equation. You have the the
temporal derivative of
of something and on the right hand side
you have a second order quantity the the
Ricci curvature that is a little bit
similar to the Laplacian. Now, of
course, it's only structural similarity
because the the the property of this
equation is very different.
I think there was a question.
Uh how to express graph positional
coordinates in a way that preserves the
invariants?
Um
It's a good question. So, I don't have
an immediate answer to this. Uh
um
Usually what you will be doing here so
the these kind of applications
uh
assume that you're working on a given
graph. So, you don't want to generalize
across different graphs. Yeah, it's it's
a very good question. So, uh
positional encoding has been used in
many different ways. So, for example,
you can use Laplacian eigen functions
for positional encoding. I think Hagai
Maron had a paper that that that looked
into it deeper how to basically combine
invariant positional coding with
equivariant message passing. Yeah, but
but it's it's very good one.
Um anyway, so um the Ricci flow works
like this and what it takes for example
when you apply it to this
dumbbell-shaped manifold that has
negative curvature in the bottom neck
and
uh positive curvature in the in the
spheres that comprise it, when you uh
evolve this manifold under the Ricci
flow and here I'm showing the the back
back road
uh flow in time, then this dumbbell
become more sphere-like and then will
collapse into a point.
And why this is important? Because this
is how we can characterize
high-dimensional spheres. So, if you
think of a two-dimensional sphere,
right? I can take a closed curve on the
sphere and collapse it into a point. So,
anything that topologically looks like a
sphere. If I have a torus for example,
so imagine that this is a torus, a curve
like this that goes across the donut
will cannot be collapsed into a point.
And uh a famous result from um Poincaré
called the Poincaré conjecture suggested
that this is how you can characterize uh
high-dimensional spheres. And actually
Ricci flows were introduced by Richard
Hamilton exactly with the scope of
proving the Poincaré conjecture. He
himself uh didn't manage to to provide a
full proof. This was done by Grigori
Perelman about 15 years ago
and that was the the breakthrough of the
year, the proof of the Poincaré
conjecture, actually more general result
that contains the Poincaré as a
particular case.
Now, uh if you ask what does it have to
do with graphs? So, somebody somebody
asked about why and how graphs can be
unfriendly for message passing. So,
here's an illustration. We have a small
world network and the volume uh in this
graph grows exponentially, right? So,
the the volume in this case you can
think of it as the sum of the degrees,
so roughly speaking the number of
neighbors
that I have.
So, if I go to the neighbors of the
neighbors of the neighbors, then their
number will grow exponentially and if I
have a task where I need to bring
information from uh distant neighbors,
then then
I have a problem with uh with
information flow.
So, uh
mathematically we can describe it as a
kind of sensitivity. So, we have a
multi-layer convolutional network. Let's
say that that the activation functions
are Lipschitz continuous,
then uh the output at node I
will depend on the input at node S that
is distant from it
through this Jacobian. So, I can write
the derivative of the output
uh of
the the last layer of the neural network
to the input uh at some node.
And uh we show that that we can bound it
well by the Lipschitz constant of the
network, but also by something that
depends on the graph. So, it will be
some power of the adjacency matrix. So,
you see that that the structure of the
graph or the bottleneck
that that might be in a graph is to
blame, but it's not very clear how it
comes across, right? So, it's somehow
hidden inside this power of the
adjacency matrix. And we know
intuitively that there will be some
graphs that are more friendly than
others for uh that are less friendly.
So, a pathological example is
uh a tree, right? So, as we go deeper
then this
the this quantity decays exponentially
with the depth.
And uh basically it me- it means that
this gradient or this Jacobian will be
very small. It means that the output of
the neural network is insensitive to the
input. It means that we have difficulty
to propagate information.
On the other hand, if we have a graph
that looks like a grid, we know that on
grids this is less of an issue. So,
somehow we need something more nuanced
than than this uh power of the adjacency
matrix to be able to distinguish between
structures like trees and grids.
That's exactly what curvature is used
for in differential geometry. So,
curvature allows us to locally
tell what is the structure of the space.
So, if I take two points and I shoot
geodesic from them, remember what
geodesics are, right? Uh in parallel and
at the same velocity, so I can track the
geodesics and see whether they will
meet, right? And in this case I'm
talking locally about something that
looks like a sphere or a positively
curved object, I can
the the then the geodesics can remain
parallel and this means that I'm locally
Euclidean, or they can diverge and in
this case the curvature is negative and
I have something that looks like a
hyperboloid.
So, the same idea can be applied to
graphs. So, we can take two nodes
connected by an edge. We can look at the
edges that emanate from it. And if they
tend to form triangles, it's the analogy
of converging geodesics. I'm looking at
something that that looks like a clique,
right?
If they tend to form rectangles, then I
look at something that looks like a
grid. And then if they become further
away from each other, right? So, I look
at tree-like structures. So, this is the
analogy of positive, zero, and negative
curvature. And we can define a curvature
Well, there are multiple constructions
of the discrete analogs of
Ricci curvature on graphs. So, this is
our construction that we call balanced
form and curvature that for every edge
computes this quantity. It doesn't
really matter what it is, but what is
important that it reproduces the
continuous behavior. So, in cliques,
edges will have positive curvature. On
grids, they will have zero curvature.
And on trees,
they will have negative curvature.
Now, the main result of the paper is the
relation between this curvature and the
Jacobian in the form that tells you that
if you have negatively curved edges in
the graph,
then you can bound the the the Jacobian.
So, it will be sufficiently small. It
means that there is insensitivity to the
input. It means that there is
over-squashing phenomenon that is caused
by the negatively curved edges.
And once we know this, right? So, we
have this geometric description, more
nuanced description of the graph,
then we can try to use something similar
to Ricci flow to cut out these
negatively curved edges and re-wire the
graph surgically
by removing these these bottlenecks.
And as a result, we get
a new structure that is not very
different from the input graph, but is
more friendly for message passing. So,
it removes these uh these kind of
bottlenecks.
So, let me show you just one thing. I
know that I'm out of time. Uh one thing
that that
uh is maybe even more exotic. And uh I
remind you that that in differential
geometry
um
manifolds are topological objects,
right? So, as we said um by this kind of
hand-waving that they have the notion of
uh
neighborhood, but not the notion of
distance or angle, right? So, graphs are
a discrete uh the a version of uh these
topological objects. So, in a graph
you do have the notion of neighborhood,
right? So, you can say who your
neighbors are, but you don't have any
geometry attached to it, right? So, it's
completely abstract uh uh combinatorial
object.
Now, in differential geometry, remember
that that we said that in order to to
basically, the manifold itself, you can
bend it in any way you want. So, if you
want to assign to a geometry, you can do
it through a metric that induces uh a
way of moving vectors on the manifold,
parallel transport, right? Uh and we
also said that more generally, you can
define connection or parallel transport
independently of the metric. So, in
other words, I can define a mechanism
that tell me how to move a vector from
one point to another, right? From the
tangent space at point U and point V.
So, you can de- de- design something
like this on a graph. So, you can say
that every node has associated vector
space, right? And the edges as well.
And uh you have linear maps that take a
vector from the between these spaces.
These are called restriction maps, and
these objects so the graph with these uh
vector spaces and the maps between them
is called a cellular sheaf.
And uh it's an object that is studied in
algebraic topology.
And uh
basically, the idea here is that we can
invent the sheaf on a graph. So, I can
you can give me a graph, I can build a
sheaf that is the best for certain
tasks. Okay? So, we can define uh uh uh
some kind of way of transporting vectors
between adjacent nodes. We can define an
analogy of the Laplacian, right? So, the
Laplacian now, if you remember what the
Laplacian did, so it averaged the
neighbors and subtracted them from the
the node itself. So, here when I bring
information from my neighbors to my
node, I will also trans- transform them
by some kind of a matrix by linear map,
right? So, basically the same way as a
vector when it moves from one point to
another on the manifold, if you have a
rotates, here I need to transform the
data before I can I can use it.
And uh what we show is that you can
always pose a classification problem as
a diffusion on a graph with these
associated shift structure, where you
can choose the shift in such a way that
you can classify your nodes. So, there
is a kind of oracle shift
that that that that you can design. And
then we can what we can do, we can say,
"Okay, I have a diffusion equation on
this cellular shift with some initial
conditions.
Uh I can look at the limit of this
equation,
and I can see what kind of
classification problems can be solved.
If I assume certain restrictions on the
way that the shift is constructed,
basically certain class or certain group
on these uh transformations between
different nodes and edges.
And uh by doing this, we can uh we can
make an analogy, or maybe we can replace
the vice for element, which is a purely
combinatorial structure,
by uh uh by a continuous diffusion
equation. Then we can talk about
expressive power, for example, by
whether we can distinguish certain
number of classes in the limit
of this
of this differential equation.
So, the last thing I would like to show,
and I will I will stop here, is remember
this metaphor of physical system for
learning on graphs.
So, we don't need to limit ourselves to
diffusion equations. We can actually
talk about, for example, a classical
mechanical system when we have uh
oscillators at every node of the graph,
and they are coupled through the edges
of the graph through some function that
is learnable.
And
basically it's
a more
complex model it also has a kinetic term
so it has both wave and diffusion
behavior so
basically the nodes oscillate and there
is also some dissipation
and we can show for example that it
avoids over smoothing and
experimental results performs better
than
than than other models so it can be
actually thought of as a wrapper around
standard
convolutional or attention
attention functions so that was a work
but that was done by Constantine Rush
and collaborators from ETH Zurich
and it was presented this weekend ICML.
So I will stop here so maybe the last
question that that I would like to ask
and it's maybe a little bit provocative
because for example Peter would probably
not agree with me is whether it's still
uh
valid to call these kind of
architectures message passing because
they are coming from
physical systems where we don't
necessarily need to communicate between
a pair of nodes so we can have systems
where for example there might be
multiple node interactions or maybe
there will be interactions at different
distances and by having this continuous
object from which we derive graph neural
networks by discretizing the the
differential equations that govern the
the respective physical system we have a
much richer space
to to draw from and to design
these kind of architectures. So I
consider this
an interesting
research direction that that
seems promising and also connects the
dots into many different domains and
physics in in differential equations
also in high performance computing
because when it comes to for example
dealing with very large graphs so the
the question of hardware how to
implement algorithms
necessarily must be taken into account.
But again I will stop here and will be
happy to answer any questions. Thank
you.